foreign
is up next in my hometown Boston
Massachusetts what's going on Jonathan
how are you sir very good how are you
very good thank you for taking my call
sure
um I'm here from uh uh from I'm an hour
from Boston
and I I love real estate but I'm
currently a truck driver and I uh
um
um I got two rental properties
in uh but I mean a hundred thousand
dollars of debt and I was wondering if
if I should uh just stick to
uh baby step number two and pay off like
slowly this debt of 100K or if I should
just sell one of these properties uh
because I have a good amount of equity
and just make that
um that step quicker to be um debt free
is is that 100K is that Consumer Debt or
is that including any debt on the
rentals as well
um that's uh that's
um no that's like 20 20K is is I owe for
my dad that I borrowed for the
renovation
um 40 is credit card
um and the rest is like uh it's all
split up in in different little things
like personal loans or what
um the rest is uh um I have uh
sorry you didn't answer my question so
the renaults are do you paid cash for
the renaults
or no I'm sorry for the rentals
no no no they're not they're both
they're both financed okay what do you
owe on each rental
one of them I owe 250
uh and the other one I owe
um 500. oh my goodness goodness gracious
are you even cash flowing on this stuff
it sounds like you're probably breaking
even if you're lucky I don't even care
um well one of them one of them
um my mortgage is 1700
and and I get and I get um
around like three three and a half
um I just feel like you're one misstep
away from this house of cards crumbling
yeah
yeah with a hundred thousand in debt and
that the 40 000 in credit cards that's
probably what 20 something percent
interest on that
yeah yeah trust me I that's why I'm
calling because I'm very stressed so I
I've always wanted to get into real
estate but I've never had somebody to
guide you so so
um I did like the opposite of what did
okay we've all done dumb and Dave did it
with a whole lot more zeros than we'll
ever know so it's okay we want to help
you and uh you can undo some of this and
I think selling the rentals is probably
part of that because right now you need
to clean slate no I I know it is George
not I think because I mean what's your
income
my income right now it's it's about a
50k a year
yeah these rentals are gone man yeah
no no you were making 300 000 I'd be
like all right let's pay off this
hundred thousand but 50k you're gonna be
crawling for years trying to pay off
this debt
yeah so so it's like uh me and my dad we
we we kind of like we bought them
together both houses we bought them
together in both of your names
no just it's all in my name it's all in
mind that's all you're dead
yeah so this is all my debt and me and
my dad are like
um we we were uh working hard on on
doing the baby step number two to pay
off this debt why is it involved with
your debt payoff forever
well because he because he uh um he
lives in in one of the the properties
and he he uh he bought it with me as
well so he's paying you rent
no no
no this is real confused right
yeah you said he lives in Roman so he's
living in one and you're not getting the
money every month in his rent he's just
what's he doing with that money that he
would have paid for you in rent
we're paying off debt we're paying off
um all this debt that we owe because we
we had to uh renovate and it was
um on pandemic okay and our in our
budget went over so we had to borrow
money this is I I I
I'm not mad at you for wanting to get
into real estate I think a lot of people
do I think a lot of people see it as a
quick path to earning money or a quick
path to wealth but there's a right and a
wrong way to do it as you're learning
and I I don't I
I'm sure that you feel an enormous
weight Jonathan right to know that you
owe 500k 250k and another 100K in debt
and I've got to believe and you can
correct me if I'm wrong but because
you're Tangled Up in this with your dad
with a family member there's probably a
lot of pressure
right to make this right and get right
side up on this and there's some sunk
cost fallacy because you guys have sunk
a lot of money into the stuff and now to
back out of all of it no we just got to
keep going we'll crawl our way out we'll
dig a hole all the way through and well
that's why it's a fallacy because just
because you got a hold of it doesn't
mean you can't stop Go a different
direction and sell off this property and
honestly what George said I 100 agree I
think that these rentals need to go on
the market today both of them if you
were to sell them today uh what would
you make off of each one
um on the the one that I that I owe 500
um which is a it's a four family on an
acre lot here in a really good uh City
okay
um I could get I could get like 400 to
500.
um inequity off that one yes inequity
hold on and I'm guessing 50 has to go to
your dad is that the the agreement
um yeah yeah that that would be the that
would be did he have the money down
yes yes uh-huh okay so let's let's
assume that I'm if you said this is a
deal you did with your dad I'm assuming
it's 50 50s so if you got 400 then you'd
get to take home 200. you're saying this
thing would sell for nine hundred
thousand
um it would sell for for a million I
already got it it sell for a million and
you're saying after the mortgage is paid
off after fees are taken out you would
walk away with 400 total
oh yeah uh with realtor real estate fee
no no
okay I would Factor all that in start to
do the math but either way if you sold
one or both of these you could pay off
all of your debt mm-hmm
and probably start to knock out the
other rental if you just sold this one
yeah exactly so the other one it's a
three family and that one
um I owe right now around 250 on it okay
in in that one I could get 400 like 500
Max okay and then split with your dad
assuming
so you'd be bringing home about 250. so
what I really want you to go away from
this call
understanding is that a you need to sell
off these properties you need to get
debt free as soon as these properties
sell but very closely underneath that I
really want to make sure that you and
your dad are very clear on what this
deal is because in asking you it kind of
sounds like oh yeah that yeah that
sounds amazing we said that yeah we need
some real clear terms yeah written in a
contract and under overarching all of
this I understand that you and your dad
went into this as a an agreement or a
deal or something that you were going to
do together sounds like nothing's in
writing and if you're feeling some sort
of pressure from your dad to hang on to
these properties because maybe he's
living in one or he feels like he's got
money to make off of it that is
something that you guys really need to
get into because all of this is in your
name right so if you want to sell them
you can
right are you feeling pressure yeah
um yeah well um I feel pressure because
like uh I live in one of the units too
so like where am I gonna put me and my
family in you're gonna have to ask my
mom my dad you're gonna have plenty of
cash after you sell these to take care
of new living situations for you and
then your dad
that's up to him to decide what he does
with his portion of the cash yeah maybe
get a primary residence where you just
live there and then if you want to buy
investment property later do it with
cash but right now I'm looking at a guy
making 50k who owes 8.50 and I can't
breathe man okay let's restart and do
this the right way